[Musique]
oui on l'entend les impacts ont émis le
fait que les gens soient plus isolé en
ce moment il ya beaucoup de sens à mon
travail
tant qu'on lisait sur le but qui fait
c'est qu'ils sont encore en vie parmi
nous bonjour elles sont au bout du fil
ou de leur clavier pour réconforter ceux
qui en ont besoin
la détresse elle la côtoie au quotidien
les demandes aides ont augmenté de lui
pour 100g suicide action montréal
ce qu'ils appellent évoque souvent la
solitude j'ai parlé à un homme d'un
certain âge il nommait cette difficulté
est de ne pas avoir de peu pour voir ses
enfants ses petits enfants
donc ce sont eux on entend assez
régulièrement
au début en mars d'un beau coup les
personnes âgées puis à deuxième
confinement c'est plus les jeunes
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'anxiété s'est
vraiment soeur pour les jeunes qui
génère anxiété qui amène à penser au
suicide
tel un bon jour j'étais le jeune les
demandes est donc grimpé de 25% à 5 h
textech un peu notre service et la
hausse est encore plus élevé pour
l'aligner faux part à un peu plus de 50
pour sa première vague les jeunes et
parents il y avait beaucoup d'inconnues
on savait pas ce qui s'en venait
maintenant avec la deuxième vague c'est
encore des moments d et clément 5
les jeunes sont un peu au bout de leur
patience
manque de motivation pour l'école et les
cours à distance sentiment d'isolement
selon myriam ds mais il ne faut pas
banaliser ce que vivent les jeunes
je pense que les adultes autour d'eux
des fois peuvent envoyer le message que
mais c'est pas grave faut passer à autre
chose faut en revenir c'est un besoin
primordial à l'adolescence de socialiser
des fois juste de reconnaître que c'est
difficile de les comprendre c'est déjà
un premier pas ça leur fait du bien
les gens ne veulent pas des conseils les
jeunes tout d'abord une écoute parce que
des conseils les jeunes 7ans six ans
reçoivent de toutes parts je n'ai juste
pas assuré la sécurité avec une jeune
danger tel jeunes que je suis suisse et
d'action puisque vous vous pensé au
suicide
on ne se désole pas nécessairement de la
hausse des appels on se dit qu'au moins
les gens vont chercher de l'aide
malheureusement d'autres restent dans
l'ombre moi je crains les packs de
limiter les rassemblements par
précaution sanitaire puis ça va affecter
le moral et la santé mentale des
personnes les plus vulnérables
on compte beaucoup sur un appel à tous
c'est à dire beaucoup plus vigilant
auprès de ses collègues de travail ses
amis ses proches ses parents al'approche
défaite
il est plus que jamais nécessaire d'être
attentif aux signes de détresse pour
éviter que des proches le souffre en
silence ici olivier bastin radio canada
montréal
[Musique]